c'est la rentrée pour moi aussi c'est la
rentrée alors bon c'est toujours un
petit peu violent un com com transition
ce que je vous propose
histoire de boucler la boucle de ce qui
a été finalement notre notre série de
l'été c'est que je vais prendre mon
petit cartable
je vais mettre mes chaussures neuves et
puis je vais aller chez le laseristes et
oui parce que si vous avez allumé la
télé vous l'avez peut être constaté
il est toujours là il s'est pas le
laseristes 1 vous voyez tout je parlais
et bah si vous avez eu l'occasion de me
croiser par exemple dans les vestiaires
de la salle de sport voulait peut-être
constaté aussi il est toujours aussi
dans mon slip afin que derrière enfin
pas dans mon slip mais enfin vous l'avez
donc pas ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on fait
comme d'habitude je vous emmène avec moi
ont fait la séance et on débrief après
allez go
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi selon vous
il ya la fréquence
arès le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui alors là à ce moment là il ya eu une
panne de courant enfin une coupure de
courant parce qu'ils avaient des travaux
dans le quartier du centre bon ça a pas
duré très longtemps
quelques minutes les fesses à l'air ce
qui fait du bien quand on a un laser qui
qui chauffe et puis le temps que la
machine se réinitialise et on est
reparti on est reparti
[Musique]
à la bible les deux ans je vais manger
parce que j'ai faim et je vous raconte
tout ça voilà donc oui la 11ème séance
parce que petit rappel j'ai fait cette
séance dans l'ancien centre avec le
laser
q switch et là c'était ma quatrième
séance avec le pico jours au centre
saint-honoré ponthieu donc c'était le
nombre de séances
on s'était dit au départ avec le médecin
mais bon ça on va en reparler après
alors petit état des lieux avant de
commencer ça c'est le tatouage il ya un
mois avant la séance précédente
et ça c'est le tatouage ce matin avant
la séance du jour voilà donc bon comme
vous voyez en un mois ça un peu évolué à
vitesse grand v mais je
les treks continue de ne pas lire il ya
des endroits où c'est les contours sont
plus floues disons il ya des endroits où
les traits commence à partir d'eau tout
ils continuent à partir et puis dont il
ya les yeux ou manifestement cessé le
boulot est bien avancé mais encore une
fois aujourd'hui comme la fois
précédente
on n'a pas touché aux yeux parce que la
peau a été bien abîmées par le cul
switch donc des séances précédentes
donc on laisse un petit peu au repos
alors voilà ça avance on n'est pas au
bout de nos peines
surtout loi mais ça avance donc vous
avez compris comme je l'avais pressenti
comme c'était évident et on en avait
parlé la dernière fois il faudra plus
que quatre séances de pick au futur pour
pour faire partir complètement tatouages
évidemment puisque aujourd'hui c'est la
quatrième donc on est reparti sur un
nombre indéterminé de séance je vais
arrêter de d'essayer de me projeter on
c'est manifestement pas une science
exacte donc disons que c'est à la fin de
la foire que l'on comptera des blues
on continue et puis on verra quand
est-ce que ça s'arrête donc avant de
vous raconter comment re comment ça
s'est passé cette fois là je vais
revenir sur un petit truc sais pas si
vous souvenez la dernière fois on avait
parlé d'un truc je devais aller me
baigner dans l'eau de mer
quelques jours pas tout à fait une
semaine après la séance de laser bombe a
donc comme prévu je n'ai pas pu résister
à l'appel du grand large donc je suis
allé me baigner et ben ça va on
s'applique pas et ça a pas eu
d'incidence sur la cicatrisation donc
pas de souci ce petit point ce petit
point baignade est en fait on va pouvoir
continuer la dernière fois je vous avais
dit que la séance avait été fait avec la
puissance maximum du laser pico jour le
top du top et que cette fois on a les
jeux sans doute changer les réglages
alors je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
en gros la puissance est lié avec la
taille du faisceau c'est à dire que
puissance maximale ça veut dire tout
petit faisceau c'est à dire le
le diamètre du laser plus il est petit
plus il est précis et plus il est
profond voilà donc vaisseau très petit
égale puissance maximale si on diminue
la puissance on élargit un peu le
faisceau dont il tape un petit peu plus
large sur au niveau des traits et un peu
moins profond voilà donc cette fois eh
ben on a refait une séance puissance
maximale des plus petits faisceau ce
qu'on a changé en revanche c'est la
fréquence c'est à dire on a fait une
séance à 10 hertz
alors que la dorna fois c'était 5 hearts
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
impulsions du laser il y en a 10 par
seconde
alors que la dernière fois on avait cinq
par seconde
au niveau du bruit vous entendez
peut-être ça fait on entend que les uns
les impacts sont plus rapprochés
ça fait comme l'a dit le médecin une
espèce d'effet mitraillette
voilà donc l avantage c'est que ça ça
martèle un peu plus sur le sur l'autre
il faut savoir que là on est au max pour
tous puissance maximale
on va pas au delà de dirty pour le four
la fréquence donc là on est on est au
max de ce qu'on peut faire
alors est-ce que c'est lié je ne sais
pas est ce que s'est dit ah la la
fréquence qu'on a augmenté tout cas j'ai
un petit peu plus senti j'ai même un
petit peu et mal cette fois
contrairement aux fois précédentes où ça
passait vraiment crème là j'ai eu une
petite douleur malgré la pommade
anesthésiant tinqueux que le médecin
valise et une heure avant comme comme à
chaque séance
là ça a piqué un petit peu plus sans
comparaison avec le cul switch
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas de pommade
anesthésiante à l'époque mais quand même
ça va piquer un petit peu ensuite pour
l'efficacité comme à chaque fois il va
falloir laisser quelques jours passés
pour se rendre compte si ça si ça
continue à pâlir s'il ya d'autres
nouveaux traits qui continua qui
continuent à partir là d'ores et déjà on
fait notre notre petit tour du
propriétaire comme d'habitude ça vous
l'avez déjà vu c'est le tatouage le
matin avant la séance
ça c'est le tatouage juste après la
séance quelques quelques heures après la
séance
quand j'ai retiré le pansement donc on
va axer rouge en voit qu'au niveau des
traits de nouveau ça fait cette espèce
de des faits un peu floutée que
j'imagine être lancre qui se fragmente
un petit peu ça c'est le tatouage le
lendemain donc j + 1 après la séance
ça c'est le tatouage deux jours après ça
c'est le tatouage
trois jours après et ça c'est le
tatouage quatre jours après crème à
chaque fois donc on verra la prochaine
fois puisqu'il faut encore une fois le
temps à l'organisme d'éliminer les
petits fragments d'encre qui ont été
broyés par par le laser
donc on se donne rendez-vous dans un
mois puisque comme vous l'avez compris
il y aura à prochain rendez-vous et même
potentiellement très probablement
plusieurs autres rendez vous à noter que
le médecin n'est pas inquiet voilà pour
lui oui ça prend du temps
il avait déjà dit la dernière fois que
bon il ça prenait il était un petit peu
étonné du temps que ça prenait
mais voilà pour lui ça suit son cours
donc je je me calque sur sa confiance
un petit truc que je me suis dis parce
que bon cet été j'ai croisé pas mal
d'entre vous dans les différentes villes
dans lesquelles je suis allée et dans
les différents festivals parce que j'en
ai en effet quelques-uns
j'ai noté qu'à chaque fois c'est
globalement les mêmes questions qui
reviennent d'abord vous me parler
vraiment systématiquement de nantes à
tout âge
je suis assez assez touché finalement de
la sollicitude et de l'implication que
vous mettez dans dans cette aventure que
je vis depuis maintenant un an et
quelques mois mais donc c'est toujours
les mêmes questions globalement qui
reviennent je me suis dit que peut-être
du coup une bonne fois pour toutes que
pour que vous ayez tous et toutes les
réponses à ces questions que
manifestement vous vous posez peut-être
que la prochaine fois je vous ferai une
sorte de petite faq au sens littéral
c'est vers le haut je répondrai aux
questions les plus fréquemment posées
voilà ça fera peut-être
et un petit point en une sorte de petit
bilan qui est qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas inutile donc du coup bah voilà
rendez-vous prochain rendez-vous laser
dans un mois entre temps bien sûr je
reprends les vidéos puisque c'est là
c'est la rentrée donc on va parler aussi
dit autre chose évidemment donc du coup
on se retrouve très bientôt pour des
nouvelles vidéos donc d'ici là mettez
vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]